this is cereth registered nurse Arion
calm and in this video I'm going to
demonstrate how to complete an abdominal
assessment and if you would like to
watch a complete head-to-toe nursing
assessment you can access this card up
here in the corner or in the YouTube
description below access to that video
now before you do this skill you'll want
to provide privacy to the patient
perform hand hygiene and tell the
patient what you will be doing and some
equipment that you will need for this is
a stethoscope so let's get started now
we're going to assess the abdomen and
remember we're switching our sequence
and how we assess we're going to do
inspection auscultation and then
percussion or palpation so we're going
to auscultation second so whenever
you're looking and assessing the abdomen
have the patient lay on their back and
what we're gonna do is we're going to
inspect the abdomen and first we want to
ask Ben are you having any stomach
issues at all no okay and when was your
last bowel movement yesterday morning
and how are you urinating do you have
any pain while you're peeing do have
problems starting a stream any discharge
anything like that okay and with your
male patients you want to ask about that
due to prostate enlargement was starting
a stream and if he was female I would
ask him when his last menstrual period
was and also again ice to be more
patient about urinating and things like
that now if the patient had a Foley this
is the time when you would want to look
at the urine inspect the Foley and look
at that just conglomerate your urinary
system in your GI system together
okay so we're inspecting the abdomen
we're looking at the abdominal contour
and this patients is scaphoid it goes in
a little bit you can also have flat
round it or protuberant and also we're
going to know if there's any pulsations
a lot of times in this area right here
on thin patients like with being I can
see the aortic pulsation in this
patients rod above the umbilicus and
looking at the belly button and checking
for any mass
do we see any hernias or anything like
that also if your patient had any wounds
you wouldn't want to look at that and if
they had a peg tube you wouldn't want to
assess the site make sure it's not red
and ask them how it feels and with your
ostomies with your ostomies you want to
look at the stoma and make sure it is
like a rosy pink color it's not a dusky
cyanotic color and it's not prolapsed
and look and see what type of stool it's
putting out and note that note the smell
note when if the bag needs to be changed
anything like that so now we're ready to
listen to the bowel sounds and what
we're going to do is we're going to
listen with the diaphragm of our
stethoscope and we are going to start in
the right lower quadrant and work our
way clockwise and we're gonna listen all
four quadrants and you should hear five
to thirty sounds per minute and if you
don't hear any bowel sounds you need to
listen for five full minutes and you
need to note are these normal are they
hyperactive or hypo active so let's
listen right lower quadrant we're gonna
move out to the right upper quadrant
move over to the left upper quadrant and
then down to the left lower quadrant
ambassy ons are normal
now we're gonna listen for vascular
sounds and you're gonna do this with the
bell of your stethoscope and we're gonna
listen at the aortic we're gonna listen
at the renal arteries iliac arteries and
you could listen at the femoral already
arteries if you need it to so you're
gonna listen at the aorta artery and
it's a little bit below the xiphoid
process a little bit above the umbilicus
so about right here and we're listening
for like a blowing swishing sound that
which would represent a bruit okay and
none is noted then we're gonna listen at
the right and left renal arteries which
is a little bit down from the aorta
location so here's
right okay none note it and then over
the left then we're gonna listen at the
iliac and it's a little bit below the
belly button right here and this is
Illya Carter II and then listen on the
other side and again like I pointed out
you could listen at the femoral artery
and the groin if you need it too now
we're going to do palpation first we're
going to do light palpation then deep
and being as I do this please tell me if
you feel any pain or tenderness so first
we're gonna do by palpation we'll just
start in the right lower quadrant and
work her way around and you're gonna go
about two centimeters and you're just
feeling for any rigidity any lumps
masses anything like that how's that
feel okay okay now we're gonna do deep
palpation and we're gonna go about four
to five centimeters so a lot more deep
then again you're just feeling for any
masses lumps and then tell me if you
have any tenderness and sometimes you
can do this with two hands if need be if
you're not strong enough [ __ ] me
telling anything feels nice and soft
hurts um belly sounds that's why you do
this after you listen because you
stimulate it good so that wraps up how
to perform an abdominal assessment and
don't forget to check out that video on
the complete head-to-toe nursing
assessment thank you so much for
watching and don't forget to subscribe
to our channel for more videos